I don't wanna go to school
I don't wanna take the call
I just wanna be a fool
Watching me, please.
With confidence, please,
everybody.
Come on!
One, two, three, four. One.
Feel it!
Hi, Adam.
-Nice summer?
-Shut the fuck up.
Tromboner, give me
what you've got.
Charlie, no. I like you,
but I'm figuring stuff out.
Literally what more
do you want from me?
He told you to stop.
Do you wanna kiss?
Would that help?
Wow.
-Just a suggestion.
-Wow.
Well, if you're not
interested…
Ok, hang on.
It's a good suggestion.
Good afternoon
and welcome to
the grand live final
of the National Student Quiz
Championship.
Tao, it's fine. I'm fine.
Truham students,
Higgs students.
Welcome to the day I know
you've all been waiting for:
Truham-Higgs Sports Day.
I auditioned for
Swing Band today.
Come on. I'm in the lead.
Can you just let me…?
Can you let me win one time?
You've already won
like five or six games.
Yeah,
and I'm going easy on you.
No.
-Yes!
-No!
How are you so good at this?
I don't know
what I am.
And who the hell am I?
Like, maybe I don't care
about anything enough.
You're 17. You don't have to
have it all figured out.